it's Chris Harrison there you sure he is
he's in Las Vegas I mentioned the finale
the live finale of The Bachelorette next
Monday on ABC the premiere of bachelor
in paradise that's a Tuesday night
also Who Wants to Be a Millionaire every
weekday Chris good morning how are you
that was a great story I did not know
that yeah well it's a painful story what
have you been offered or thought you
were going to get any other game shows
besides bachelor bachelorette my big
break that I thought when I first moved
to LA I was doing actually a
horse-racing network called TBG which
did go and while I was there I went an
audition for this this is early 2000s a
show called Ripley's Believe It or Not
yeah Dean Cain Dean Cain yeah and but so
Dean was just coming off Lois and Clark
at the time and I auditioned signed the
contract done deal and at the time this
was you know changing my life big thing
told the wife were celebrating and next
thing I know Dean is leaving Lois and
Clark he's a big name
nobody knows who Chris Harrison is Dean
Cain took over who Ripley's Believe It
or Not yeah but you might not have
gotten the bachelor/bachelorette exact
no look everything happens for a reason
you know I even I remember after the
bachelor had been going for about a year
we had been on a couple of seasons and I
got a call about this this really
bizarre singing show that Fox was doing
and but don't worry about going to the
audition it's a mess they don't even
know what it is who knows what it'll
turn out to be and of course it turns
out to be American Idol so fired that
agent by the way but yeah you know
there's so many things through this
business and there's a I'm sure you have
a dozen stories too where we often get
used as pawns in a game where say
they're having trouble negotiating with
Regis or negotiating with somebody
they'll bring someone like you in or me
in two very publicly audition just to
get the other person to you know sign
and quit playing hardball and so you
know you get used at times it's really
bizarre the different stories and shows
that come and go and why you get them
but I'm a firm believer things are meant
to be and I think that turned out okay
with the Batchelor franchise I think
it's gonna be alright
I was used I think by Good Morning
America years ago when I went in to
co-host for three days this is when
Charlie Gibson was the main host and I
guess that there were contract
negotiations so they brought him in then
put it in USA Today that I'm being
considered for the permanent role and
then I think quickly Charlie Gibson
you know signed or resigned and came
back in I had no interest in doing Good
Morning America I mean if it was good
afternoon America or good evening
America but not good morning Chris no
not good after 18 holes of golf
all right the level of drama on The
Bachelorette this year how in scale one
to ten well it's ratcheting up I mean I
would say it was probably like you know
a three or four on the Richter scale of
drama and then you know yeah it's kind
of really coming to a head even last
night with the tell-all I wasn't
expecting that level of man tears and
drama and Colton which was kind of
fascinating and obviously I maybe you
guys are talking about this and the
whole you know atmosphere and in a pro
locker room and how athletes act and how
they're treated was it was fascinating
the way he opened up in Jason his tears
last night so I feel like now we're up
to about a seven or eight and I know
what's coming next week in the Maldives
in the finale and that's about a 12 of
how gutting that is but Chris how do you
hide what you already know as the host
that is one of the difficult things
about being the host of this show and
Mike Fleiss the creator of the show and
I have always had this this interesting
conversation of how I walk the line of
everybody knows I'm in on this and I
know but I have to not act like I don't
know but ask the questions that the
people at home will want to know and and
that is an interesting way to kind of
walk as a host because you know
typically you're asking a question that
you know and you're not sure what the
answer is going to be but I think it
kind of helps me because I know the
truth and so when these guys or these
women try to pull one on me or have a
little revisionist history I can quickly
call them on and say no no I was there I
know what you did and said let's let's
rethink this and and so I think I
actually get a little bit more candid
honest answers because they can't lie to
me who deserves to be the leader in the
clubhouse
as the next Bachelor because I'm gonna
put in a grocery Joe
well here's the thing Joe Joe is a
leader Joe showed a solid 69 and was the
leader early on
Colton Colton came in and in put up a 68
but then you know with the man tears
last night damn Jason shot about a 66
and so right now I'd say Jason just by
looking at my Twitter feed and
everything else he seems to be the
leader in the clubhouse but Joe and Joe
goes on to paradise and I also think
that you saw that Joe is a man of very
few words it was a little bit like
interviewing Shannon Miller back in the
day at the Olympics if you remember that
throwback of like getting the one-word
answers it was very difficult and we
kind of need our backs or to Emoto
particulate their feelings yeah so while
he's a good guy I'm not sure he would be
the best bachelor but Colton got a
little buzz in you know like it's it's
always who did America Lassie
crying in the back of a limo that's
usually who has the groundswell of
support so right now it's Jason but then
next week you're gonna see somebody else
you know heartbroken and devastated and
maybe they'll take over which NFL player
would you most want to see on The
Bachelor man that's a good question
that's a really good question you know I
used to think Dez you know he would be
really good Tony Romo but I think he's
married with 15 kids now so Tony's out I
got a couple of them for you who Jared
Goff he would be great first of all he's
already in LA I know Jared he's a good
guy and a pretty solid golfer that would
work there you gotta have Gronk in there
he would be good
Gronk clone can't be the bachelor but I
want Gronk there is he is he an advisor
to the bachelors
well Gronk I want in bachelor in
paradise
oh my because he will come in blow
everything up probably be with every
woman every woman want to be with him he
is the life of the party that's who you
need in paradise what's the craziest
thing you've seen or heard like ever on
the show yeah man
weird night first of all the craziest
thing I ever went there was the Jason
Molly Melissa switch just because no we
had never done anything like that on TV
and it was around the time that things
we'll explain that to the audience who
may not be Jason Mesnick was our
bachelor he we were in New Zealand he
proposed to this girl Melissa who was a
former Dallas Cowboy Cheerleader
actually and he broke up with this girl
Molly and we all kind of thought he was
going to propose to Molly because Molly
was the girl and they just seemed
perfect but for some reason I don't know
what it was he just he ended up
proposing to Melissa
fast forward a few months he decides
he's breaking up he wants to call Molly
and and be back with her and give this a
shot and we had never been down that
road before and it was around the time
that you know tabloids and things like
that started reporting things before we
could really show it so we thought how
do we own this story how do we put our
light on it and so we actually sat them
down and did an interview without an
audience it was just in this just kind
of dark quiet studio and he broke up
with Melissa on TV and then we brought
Molly out who did not know what was
happening and he asked her out and it
all just unfolded in front of you and it
was just one of those moments you get in
TV where you're like this could not be
more raw more uncomfortable more real
and you just it was I felt like as a
host I shouldn't be here I wanted to dig
a ditch and just crawl out of there but
that's how you know it was really honest
but didn't you get criticized yeah of
course right then I told my mom to pipe
down look we get criticized all the time
the way we handled Ari and the way we
showed everything about his breakup with
Becca and the way and what happened with
that you know you were gonna get
criticized no matter what you do if you
try to please everybody in this business
you will please nobody so my feeling is
and and and Mike Fleiss and I talk about
this all the time I make the best
decision I can with the information I
have at that time and then I stand
behind it and I will I'll go you know
I'll fight for that because you know
look it's easy to wake up on Monday
morning and tell the quarterback what he
did wrong when you slow everything down
but we don't have that benefit you have
to have these real-time answers and you
got to go with it catch the live finale
of The Bachelor
next Monday on ABC this is at the
Maldives yeah we take off to the
Maldives which apparently is as far
around the world as you can possibly go
from Los Angeles Ramallah see ya you
know it's not good when they say well do
you want to go through Dubai or you want
to go back through Asia and I said wait
it's equal and they're like yeah you can
pretty much go any way you want you're
on the other side of the world but it
was spectacular
so you're look are you looking for
sympathy that you had to go all the way
to the Maldives here dan dan you don't
understand that the troubles of my life
one of the MALDI so you got beautiful
women you got exotic locations I don't
know how you do it I would I be hosting
Who Wants to Be a Millionaire right now
if you had gotten that job yes
in a weird butterfly effect you may be
responsible for me being here in Vegas
right now hosting Who Wants to Be a
Millionaire mm-hmm I'm sure you do a
better job than I do there have been
been a few people Meredith Vieira did it
region I don't know who else did it they
had a odd Cedric the Entertainer Terry
Crews episode for a couple years that's
good guy you know and then I've taken oh
I've been doing it for four years now
good for you no I'm happy for you I'm
happy that something is is going well
finally catching some breaks yeah are
you a huge Cowboy fan diehard okay
born and raised yeah I'd explain Dez
Bryant Jerry Jones where you want to
start here no the dead thing I'm all for
uh yeah I think he was a distraction and
a bit of a cancer on the team I feel
like Dax felt like he had to get him the
ball he had to treat him like he was
Jerry Rice but he's not Jerry Rice you
know he wasn't he'll make a circus catch
but then he'll drop five other balls
that he should have had so I think you
know for DAC and for the rest of the
team it was it was tough to force the
ball to him if he's not going to deliver
and beyond that when you have a guy like
Shawn Lee who is the mother Teresa and
and you know the captain of this team
when he speaks out against you and says
you're a destroyer
in trouble you got to believe that guy
and you got a you got to put some weight
into that and so in the fact that nobody
is exactly knocking down his door I
think speaks volumes as well here's
another thing and I mentioned this
earlier and I don't want to blindside
you with it but you know Gerry Jones's
is a hypocrite when it comes to the
anthem and that you know if you don't
stand for the anthem you're not gonna
play for the Cowboys but he has no
problem bringing in Greg Hardy who you
know domestic violence or you know some
of these other characters that he's
brought in they can be Cowboys but if
you don't stand for the anthem and then
there's video of Jerry standing during
the anthem with his hat on he was told
you got your hat on kept his hat on
while he's you know they're they're
playing the anthem so I I have a problem
with Jerry when it comes to being
hypocritical here where is the hypocrisy
in bringing someone in and feeling you
know once once Jerry and Steven and the
organization feels someone you know has
either paid the price or is ready to
fully rehabilitate or whatever it is and
have a second chance what is the
hypocrisy of that versus feeling that
look the people that are paying paying a
ticket in here and people that want to
come to this show and that's what
they're doing they're not playing
football they're entertaining they're
putting on a show and where is it that
you can't come and come in and put on
this show the way they want this show
produced and part of that is standing up
for the anthem supporting in their mind
and in the fans mind supporting America
being proud of this country not to say
you can't speak up on violence what it
whatever cause you think you were
fighting mmm
maybe there's a time and a place for
that elsewhere in in that maybe that
where the NFL needs to go give these
guys an outlet to speak give them a
chance to speak on their causes whatever
it is that doesn't need to be a part of
this production and I think that's what
people forget is that this is a
production every Sunday well the NFL
made it a production though Chris
because oh they the NFL gapped this
worse than the USGA screws up the US
Open I mean it it is you know the NFL
should have nip this in the bud gone to
the players gone - ever been fix this
immediately they let this go thinking
that it was just smoke and there was no
fire
now it's burning out of control and
they're trying to you know put it out
now and no they they absolutely let this
thing get out of control which is
unfortunate because it doesn't need to
be it's just like The Bachelorette it's
out of control you know but it needs to
be out of control no it needs to be out
of control right well some things do
some things need to be you know speaking
of the NFL some things new do need to
get it out of control so you can fix it
and you can these guys can be heard need
to be heard but I don't I I see where
Jerry is coming from and and when you
have DAC and you have Zeke and these
guys get it and they stand behind Jerry
and not just because he's their boss but
if you talk to anybody from Jason
wedding to Tony Romo these guys know
that Jerry takes care of them he is a
loyal good guy to them you know say what
you will about him but you know he you
know his players stand behind him and so
I get where he's coming from
I get where the NFL is coming from but
just as you said I understand where the
players are coming from - and you're
right they should have taken care of
this a long time so now how do you put
that genie back in the bottle gonna
Ratchet it up to a 12 how many like
tears how much how much how many cheers
we're gonna have a nice season Pam is
Becca is literally brought to her knees
got it with what's about to happen on
next Monday night next Monday night more
girls been through enough Chris but it I
can tell you you know all it ends well
but to get to the good part she's kind
of got to go through the tough part
first no yeah no spoilers no spoilers
okay I tell all the people that I could
have been working with and Who Wants to
Be a Millionaire that I I say hello you
know how upset everyone's gonna be wait
a minute we could handle a magic instead
of you to this day literally last week
while I'm shooting one of the audience
members walking out goes hey your
passion bucketful people still talk
about the passion pocket you came
through big time man came to the big
time Thank You bud hey great to talk to
you Chris
hope to see you doing yep all right
that's Chris Harrison he's the host of
the bachelor and bachelorette yeah he
dropped a passion
bucket there how long ago was that I
forgot all about that good it's good
I think I don't like 4 months ago was it
when we saw him at Pebble Beach was that
yeah he'd think he did it like in March
okay
yeah McLovin it's a little easier for
him though bees passion is like the main
topic of the show so passion bucket
actually makes sense in that context
yeah but nobody says passion bucket
except for Rick Neuheisel
and Kobe and Kevin Locke yeah a lot of
people did it but you know at the time
people like passion bucket what for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]